Good evening.
As evening thank you
tonight is a great night. I'm so
glad you decided to be a part of this if you're a guest here
and we want you to know we're thankful
that you're here. We pray that you would come. So if you want to register your
attendance here, you can see that QR code and the feedback in
front of you just click a picture of that and fill out that form and
we would love to be able to get back with you and say welcome. So tonight
we continue our series on what
is our role as the culture begins
to change in a manner that we don't completely see
where it's going or we don't always agree where it's going but tonight
is refreshing night because you're
gonna get to meet some people that frankly I'm kind
of falling in love with these people and my my
part here is just to remind us that we understand
that we are created in the image and likeness
of God which gives us incalculable worth in
the side of all and so everyone should be treated as if they
are created in the image of God because
They are.
And as soldiers of Jesus Christ in the Gospel Kingdom
of the Gospel, we are here to
Bear one another's burdens. We're here to come alongside one
another and to encourage and support one another and we're going
to learn better how to do that tonight. And so we're going to start with
one of our elders you guys know, Joe Williams and Joe's
got a little testimony and a challenge for us
before we start our panel discussion. So Joe.
Thanks, Phil.
Again, my name is Joe Williams. I'm an elder here. I've been
an elder since 2005. I was
a sophomore in high school.
When I heard that Martin Luther King Jr.
Had just been killed.
I was with one of my high school teachers.
Whose comment was well one less troublemaker?
I think I agreed with him.
For too many years.
My attitude has been I'm not a racist.
So it's not my problem.
The Civil Rights bill was passed in 1964.
And it's illegal to discriminate.
So wouldn't you say then that our society is appropriately colorblind.
I guess I thought that racial issues were pretty much
overblown.
And that black people just need to chill
out.
But a few years ago, I was talking to a young pastor.
A friend he was young man originally from Tennessee who had
relocated up to Minneapolis.
And as a result of the racial tension in the Minneapolis area, he went
on a civil rights tour.
of the South with a group of pastors
these pastors were half about half black
and about half of them were white.
I asked him how that went. And he said
it really changed his perspective. And I said well,
how's that what stood out?
He mentioned that they had a stop. It stopped
at several places through the South.
But they stopped at the 16th Street Baptist Church in
Birmingham, Alabama.
We're in 1963 a bomb went off.
And four black girls were killed.
He related that as they stood around the memorial.
He was stunned as the black pastors.
began to weep
see it was personal for them.
In a way, that was really eye opening for my friend.
My friend told me that he realized that those weren't for little black
girls.
They were four little girls who were killed whose
only crime was going to Sunday school.
That made it personal to me.
Because I was a dad who took little girls to
Sunday school.
And made it personal to me for the first time.
And as it looked into it, I learned that no one was arrested for
that crime until 45 years. Later.
and so
my mind got to Reeling I said well ask my
friend. How could I learn to understand this shared personal
experience?
of our black friends
He mentioned a book by Pastor John Perkins.
Let Justice roll down.
I recommend that book it's on a resource list that we have there at
the back.
There's a man I work for work with from Kansas City. He's
a black gentleman who owns car dealerships. He's
founded Ministries.
He's a Bible vocational pastor.
He was born up in Guthrie.
We're open Wichita graduated from Langston University.
And he shared with a small group of us a few years ago.
At a time when he was he's really distraught over
ongoing racial violence.
He said I was one of the first black police officers
in Wichita.
He said I'm not a big guy.
So I know how scary it is for a policeman to confront a 240
pound violent drunk who's been beaten on
his wife.
And he said but and I know what it is as a black man to get
stopped and thrown up on the hood of a car for no good reason at all.
He said we talk about reconciliation, but
How do we reconcile that which was never consiled in
the first place?
Well, the answer of course is through Jesus Christ. Amen.
As a Believer I am precious in a sight.
And you are too.
And so are our black brothers and sisters.
We Are All Made In His Image
It raises questions in my mind.
Should I be concerned to learn?
that a child born in a particular zip code in Oklahoma City
as an 18-year shorter life expectancy.
Than a child born in another zip code in Oklahoma City.
Should I be concerned if a great majority?
Of children in that neighborhood can't read by the time they're in
the third grade.
And may never learn to read.
Am I supposed to do something about that?
Or we supposed to do something about it.
Well, Jesus say
Matthew 5 Matthew 25:40
says in the king is Jesus.
We'll answer them.
Truly I say to you.
As you did it to one of the least of these my brothers
you did it to me.
I'm really excited.
That we're joined here this evening by some folks who are doing
something about it.
And I pray as we sit at their feet tonight that
we learn from them.
So I'll turn it back over to Phil to do the next introduction. Pardon
me julita prayer. Oh.
Heavenly Father
we just come before you.
knowing that we fall short
knowing that
you love.
all people
and that we are called.
challenged to do the same
and father and knowing that we are blessed.
As we reach across the perceived boundaries that
seem to divide us.
so father we ask tonight that you would just open our hearts
to to hear things that may be hard to hear
hear things that may be exciting to hear father but
things that will
Line with the gospel.
For that is the answer. You are the answer
dear Jesus. Thank you in Jesus name I pray
amen.
Amen, I want to introduce you to our panel and you
can respond accordingly by thanking them for being here. You guys
know conedra media Medina she works
here in our staff and she's recommended our first
panel member and this is her cousin Tasia mindiola,
so welcome her.
Tasia is a professional counselor. And she's also the
managing director at the pathways to heaven and in
say well.
Hey Pathways to Haven. So
yeah, anyway made
my first mistake and I don't feel too bad about it actually, but now
the
rest of these guys all work on the same staff and they've got a great
story and many of you already know them and I
want you to I'm gonna say everybody's name that I'm gonna turn it over
to John Mark. This is Pastor John Mark Hart and Jared
Stevens on the end of there and here in between them is
a Chelsea Shiloh. So let's welcome the staff from
Christ Community Church.
I'm gonna give this to
John Mark Hart the pastor and have him share a
little about their story and then he'll introduces a comrades.
I want to first. Thank my friend Joe for what
you just shared brother.
I've known Joe. I can't remember when we met but for a number of years. I
hadn't heard you share all that story and
I think on talking about some of
the difficult challenging issues that we're talking about tonight you going first?
And sharing with humility and honesty about your own
journey is just so powerful.
And I've been reading in James lately, which says
God opposes the proud but give grace to the humble. Do
you feel like we need some more humble in America?
and there's a lot of Shame there's a
lot of anger but part of how we do things in the body of Christ James one also
says let every person be quick to
hear slow to speak slow to
anger and I think just the opportunity now to embrace
the
a humility of listening humility of speaking even sharing weaknesses and
growth and your own blind spots is awesome. James
also says confess your sins to one another and pray for
each other so that you may be healed.
So that just sharing honestly about your own journey and everyone listening is
great. That's great. Where you start Joseph? Thank you for sharing with vulnerability.
So I'm supposed to tell a little bit about our story Redemption Church
is the church. We work on in South Oklahoma City we and
I have several generations of family history
in South OKC.
and
my dad grew up in South OKC went to
Grant High School and didn't know the Lord when he was a
senior in high school. He was struggling spiritually and
getting in to a lot of trouble and and just didn't
know God and was trying to figure out what life was about and actually one
night. He went out to buy drugs, but it was too cold
so he couldn't find anyone in and turn on the TV there was
a preacher you may have heard of named Billy Graham preaching on TV and saying
what he always says Jesus died on the cross for your sins and you
must be born again and my dad was like that's what I need. I need forgiveness. I
need a new start and that was the big what led to
me getting to grow up in a home that was filled with the Gospel of Jesus
Christ and many many years later.
I was at OU and through a long series of events. I went
to the whole thing since the Lord was calling me to
plant lead to team that was planning a church and felt
called to do inner city Ministry work.
I'd been doing that kind of I'd grown up in the inner city in Texas and a
multiracial environment and had been doing
that kind of been a part of that kind of ministry most of my life and felt called
to do that work and we're hoping that inner
city missions and Ministry preaching the gospel making disciples loving
our neighbors could be something not only that we do locally but
a way that we train people and that environment to go to the Nations learn
how to do missions locally in order
to learn how to do missions globally and felt like
the Lord was directing to Oklahoma City teamed up
with Chansey. He was one of eight people that came and helped us plant at that time. It was Christ
Community Church. We'll talk about the name change in a second, but
Um felt directed to a specific neighborhood and South
Oklahoma City and subsequently found out
it was the neighborhood my dad grew up and came to the Lord and I didn't know that.
And but the neighborhood had changed since then.
So when my dad grew up in South Oklahoma City, it was
known as the rep was that this was the poor white
part of Oklahoma City.
And of course black folks were institutionally segregated on
the east side northeast side at this point and the north
side was more affluent. And that was the Dynamics
of what I grew up in but a few years after he graduated from Grant as
many of you will remember finally in
Oklahoma City Federal desegregation laws
were enforced and busing started happening. It was a very difficult
time of transition, but a lot of people from the East side,
Where bus to the South Side in fact, some of my friends are a pastors on
the east side now Pastor Derek Scobee Ebenezer Baptist Church
told me the other day that he was bused down to Roosevelt where
Chauncey leads ministry right now in our neighborhood on the South
Side. So as that started happening, we also started having more
people black people moved to the South Oklahoma City and it
started triggering a phenomenon that happened all over
the United States that historians call
white flight.
People were leaving and maybe it's because
they were racist or maybe not so much. Maybe they're
just making a they're people that were already struggling financially and
they're making a sort of got to take care of my family calculation
that they're you know, supply and demand if a minority
Community moves into a neighborhood the majority Community doesn't
want to live there anymore property values are going to drop and so people started
moving out and and that is
what happened property values drop school started struggling
to a much higher degree and then over the course of
decades there started being a lot of immigration into South,
Oklahoma City.
And mostly first generation immigrants from Mexico
some coming from through, California on the way.
And that those Latino communities were rebuilding
really what had been a abandoned.
There's a lot of
Poverty and struggling realities in South
Oklahoma City, which was really a part of that Legacy of racism. But
the Latino Community came and was rebuilding very entrepreneurial
family-oriented wonderful neighbors, but also
at the same time there was ethnic tensions and
there were racial tensions as some of those folks that came through California brought some
game culture with him. And if you were around 20 years ago
in Oklahoma City, you probably remember things on the news about gang shootings. And
that's when we lost Crossroads mall and you know, just a lot of tragic violence
that was happening at that time.
And so by the time I came
was called by God back to the place where he found my dad.
what had been the poor white part of town had become
the very poor multi-ethnic part of town about 60% Latino,
but lots of black folks
lots of poor white people Vietnamese Native
American really diverse community and we
since God calling us to go into that community and preach the
gospel and make disciples and love our neighbors and
John Cena and six have our closest friends and chances
are living there teaching at Santa Fe South but we
moved into that neighborhood and and part of what we
knew was like there's a long history of Brokenness here and
we know Jesus he's the solution. He's
the answer, but also we need to come with a posture
of humility recognizing we are not the answer.
And we need to build a lot of relationships and learn this
community and we started moving into some apartment complexes
up and down Southwest 59th Street those communities were more majority
black and probably lower-income white
folks is the second largest group and and the Tina folks mixed in
with that. We started moving into those apartment complexes building relationships
starting Evangelistic Bible study sharing the
gospel people started responding to the gospel and we
were actually really intentional about we're not
going to try and start a lot of Mercy Ministries programs as if
we know what the solution is in this community we're going
to try and do is share the gospel meet neighbors listen to
one another and trust that as Jesus is going
to reconcile us and then as a reconciled community
living out what Galatians 3 says in Christ,
there's neither Jew nor Greek either slave nor free no male
and female, but you're all one in Christ Jesus as we live out that
reality God's Gonna teach us how to
do what Galatians 62 says which is bear one another's burdens
and so fulfill the law of Christ and so at
first
I was happening just in really organic ways as people were coming
to know the lord. It's like hey Grandma, Carol just got evicted who can open their home
for Grandma Carol to stay with her for a couple months or Joey
wants to go back to school at o Triple C. Let's pass
the hat to pay his fees that he owns them so he can get back into school
but over time.
All the things Jesus talks about and models as far as loving our neighbors
holistically. We just started
seeing over and over certain issues that would pop up again. And so we just
started different Ministries a Chauncey leads a great schools Ministry Outreach team
that's doing gospel Ministry and supporting teachers and supporting kids
of the 16 schools in our
17 Schools elementary schools in our neighborhood some like that a few
years ago. We saw the data that about 90% of
kids and correct me if I get the data wrong or y'all can
just assume these are estimates, but it's about
90% of kids in third grade. We're reading below.
A grade level in third grade and the problem with
that is there's a lot of correlations between third grade
reading level and going to graduate high school. And
then there's a lot of correlations between dropping out of high school and
ending up in jail. So there's this sort of
invisible pipeline between underfunded Intercity schools and
overcrowded jail systems. And
so that is a thing and as the
people of God, we've got to be Salt and Light in that area. So how do we step into
that through advocacy through service your church
you may or may not know ministries of Jesus really helped us
get off the ground Christ Community health Coalition Hilltop Clinic,
which is doing phenomenal work providing free
care for lots of people without insurance and providing affordable care
for people that are on soon to care. That's a very high quality. So addressing those
needs was just kind of growing organically out of
it. So I'm about to stop talking now, but what I would say at this point
is not very long ago.
We had been praying Lord. We need to be more effective at bilingual
Ministry in reaching our Latino brothers and sisters and one
of our partner churches that we've been working with
for a long period of time Rancho Village Baptist Church, which at
this point was a mostly Latino Spanish-speaking but bilingual Church
reached out to us and said hey,
We need leadership. We we don't have
a pastor right now. We love what you're doing. We maybe
we should start worshiping together and see if God wants to lead us to
unite. So Christ Community Church then merged with
Rancho Village Baptist Church, and now we're Redemption Church
and it's just beautiful to see there's probably about seven or eight
ethnicities most Sundays in our congregation. We're doing everything bilingual in
English and Spanish and it's just a powerful picture that the gospel
really does have the problem to bring the power to
bring people together. And then as we learned to love each other and listen
to each other in relationship God's people really have an
opportunity to be light. So I was supposed to tell our story and you should never tell
a church planter tell a story in 10 minutes because I was probably 14 or
something. So but I'm supposed to introduce these brothers. So Chancey Shiloh
brother from another mother we've been walking together for a long
time. He's awesome. He loves Jesus. He's a black
man who speaks Spanish and can seamlessly blend with
any ethnic group. He's like the perfect missionary guy
to help with what we're doing right now and Jared Stevenson
another great.
And I've got to get love to work with good friends
strong brother and he's like the inner city youth Whisperer
whose discipling a mentoring all these kids all over the South Side.
So welcome these guys.
Thank you, John Mark more honor than I deserve honestly
always appreciate you brother. Yeah, always well.
I've been
tasked with giving a brief bit about my
testimony. And so I want to share a few things. Obviously.
There's a lot of things that God has done in all of our Lives. Amen. There's so
many more if we can tell stories for ages but a
couple things that I think are relevant this afternoon
this evening are the so my
dad. I guess my dad. My dad came
to Christ in south Louisiana. And so he
grew up basically living his home
with living basically sharecroppers down in
south, Louisiana, and he would
go to school from basically from
October through about March or April because he was
the oldest brother and his family and so he had to work the field. So
as soon as harvest starts he's out working and yeah,
he still was able to graduate like third in his
class from from high school.
As the oldest brother he was supposed to stay
behind and work the fields. We graduated from
high school, but he sold a sow and three piglets to pay for
his first semester to Grambling State University up
in grammling University. I'm
going to Louisiana so into
HBC you graduated three and a half years was an accounting major
and then moved to Dallas my mother grew up in
East Texas Nacogdoches, Texas, and she was
in the Piney Woods out east and
she grew up her father was
Native American and white and her mother was black
and she grew up did
great in school. And then she entered into
Stephen F Austin State University and when
she entered into SFA she was in the first African-American
class that they let into the university that
the president University was fairly Progressive.
And so he he knew that in East Texas
they would be some pushback.
If he let blacks come into the school, so he
reached out to an African-American Pastor a couple
towns away and said hey, would you come take some classes this summer?
We're letting in some African-Americans next fall.
But if you come in this summer, I'll have an excuse that we will
ask me. Why are you letting African Americans know our College? I'll
say we've had African-Americans in our College. What are you
talking about? So this pastor came into classes that summer and
my mom got to be in the first black class to go through and she
told some stories about that one of those that were
I think it pretty relevant is she's in a course in which
she was the only African-American which upon most of her course. She's an education
major and the professor used the inward
during class and everybody looked at her.
The professor clearly did not like my mother and didn't want her
and her in his class and then
subsequently gave her a D in the course.
My mother was a tenacious Fierce Jesus
follower. So she
signed up for that exact same Professor. The next
semester made us see in his class got her
bachelor's degree and then got a master's degree from that same institution and
then moved to Dallas to teach teach elementary
school my mom and dad met there in Dallas.
They then moved
to Alaska moved back to Texas back to Alaska. I had
my twin sister and I went back to deck to Texas into a majority white
neighborhood out in Lucas Texas.
Just east of Plano Texas. If you know Plano and I grew up
there going to private schools part
of a Southern Baptist
Church out in the country and that's where I gave my life
to Jesus. So I grew up listening to pastors
from I'm sure prices
that you know, because I know that I mean North Dallas was like the
Hub of evangelicalism back in the 90s the mecca.
Yeah, exactly exactly. I
Promise Keepers back and take the stadium. So we all work. So as we
all know so that was home.
And grew up got a heart to share the gospel heart to
love Jesus. I went to a massive Plano High School.
And really I got a heart there to reach high
school students for Jesus fast forward to Oklahoma.
I got on scholarship to come to University of Oklahoma
got here and I was sitting in a class called
black white relations and in America
taught by a professor named George Henderson, George
Henderson was the third black professor that OU
hired. In fact when he came on campus the first day to go
teach his first class. He walked up to the what's now the
price College of Business and one of the students who was going to be in his class
looked at him and saw his skin color and said you got
to get out of here man, because the professors coming and then
he walked in and talked to class.
At that time Norman. We're still a sun downtown so he couldn't live inside the
Norman City Limits, but he helped to integrate that University. And
in that class. He posed a question for me
that changed my life. It's what Dr. Brenda Salter
McNeil would call a catalytic event that changed
my perspective on it shocked me
out of my normal.
And that was the ask the question to this this class,
which is majority African-American.
But I was with African-American with
an Alma Latina like a brown soul with a
majority white background.
And he said when you see a police officer, what
do you think?
and my response was
well, obviously it's now safe wherever we are is now a
safe place to be.
And the one of the guys in my group who is
from Houston, Texas. He said man, I'm getting out of here because it
just got scary if the police showed up. It just got
scary.
and I was like
What are you talking about?
You weren't an AP classes in a white Southern and
white Suburban High School in Texas. What are you talking about?
And it took me on a journey that actually
didn't go straight to the African-American experience because
subsequent to that. I got hired on at Santa Fe South Charter High
School teaching with Mr. Adrian Savage over here. Got to watch I got
to watch him. He's an excellent teacher.
And I was faced with the reality that a lot of my students
were not only my students and not only
Hispanic many of them were undocumented. In fact Santa Fe South used
to extend their Christmas break from two weeks to three weeks because
they knew that students are coming back from Mexico and they wouldn't make it across the
first time.
And I when I was in AP economics in
high school, I took a test on where I fell in the political spectrum and
I was the I was the only black kid in the class and I was the furthest on the right.
And so all of my politics aligned with the
Republican Party.
But my students.
Had issues and I loved my students.
They invited me to their quinceañeras. They give me carne asada. They fed me
enchiladas Verdes like these were my kids. These are my family. And so
when one of my kids is that
cross country practicing is a phone call from his mom saying I'm not going to
see you again guys got deported.
Or when I'm talking to to my
senior in high school I've had for for four
years and he says or for two years and I say hey, what
are you gonna do next year is that I don't know probably gonna go work on concrete. It's
like we just like we're not gonna go to college like shall I
want to go to college? It's not gonna give me papers not gonna
be able to get a job.
So I'm gonna do that.
And I watched Hope being taken away from kids.
Because of their background experience that they didn't
have any control over and it shook me.
to say
I've got to be involved in in this because my kids really
matter.
And then after helping plant Christ Community Church actually meeting John Mark.
He began to show me that not all black people
were like me.
And that my heroes weren't the only black people who
are alive.
And it took me on a journey of this whole idea of racial reconciliation.
That is given me I'm still learning about what
empathy really means.
that empathy isn't just
Agreeing that you could have that perspective but trying to actually see
what it might feel like to be in this person's shoes.
And then to walk out what Jesus says about
loving my neighbor.
That's a little bit of my story. I took I took pastures. Thank
you. It's Jared.
I know he's already been introduced. But this is my brother from another mother
so all of us and we used to
live together.
Yeah, so my journey is a
little bit different than chances and
that is wonderful. And I love me and
walking alongside him and John Mark
and you know my I have a
beautiful wife. She's not here today and she's
white.
I have two little kids
one three years old the three
year boy named rashan, and then I got a six year
old girl named Ayana.
They were half white half black.
I grew up in Broken Arrow,
Oklahoma and Broken Arrow,
Oklahoma is majority White.
My parents both of them didn't have
a father in their life.
my story starts
with
some pain sometimes
my grandmother was a
Beautiful woman a strong black woman like
your mother it's a that's
a really beautiful story man. I you know some of those things you shared
I didn't even know that bro the okay. Yeah,
man, that's what a beauty about
like coming and hanging out and doing things with your friends.
You learn stuff. It's awesome anyway, but I my
grandmother was a strong black woman and she
during the time
in which you were in classroom
with Dr. Martin Luther King died. She was
awesome in a classroom crying.
And she grew
up and she always had a motto which
is like wherever there's white people there. I am also
she passed that on to my my mother
my grandma used to walk down the streets.
She used to work for the county clerk office in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
She'd walk down streets and she'd pick up change off the
ground because she was so poor. She can she couldn't pay for
the parking downtown, but she knew that she needed to
provide for her family.
As she grew up.
She kept on leading us all to Jesus.
She took us to a church of Christ called North Peoria Church
of Christ on the north side of Tulsa. And
that's where I grew up. That's where I was introduced
to Jesus at 10 years old. I was baptized in
the name of Father Son and the Holy Spirit and came
no Christ. But as
you know, sometimes the way
that we grow is not always in a straight line.
Sometimes it's not
in a straight line is sometimes it's here and
there and up and down and in when
it comes to Breaking generational chains.
It is not so not straight line all the
time. It can be in Jesus. But sometimes
it's not like that and for my family that was
not the case see when I became a teenager.
life started getting hard
The my family is a relationships are coming apart.
They were breaking apart. There was some
things that happened that made it to where we didn't know if
we were going to stay together as a family.
The same things of the past
that were handed down were happening to
our family again.
and and God somehow
made a way for us and he kept
us and there's forgiveness and Reconciliation
in the household and it was really beautiful. And
so I got to stay with my parents and they
kept working it out and I grew up
with my parents and then
I will so somehow got good at basketball. I don't know
maybe being six four years also kind of helpful, too and
And so I started playing basketball and and got
really good and got a scholarship.
And my mom used to keep saying this thing to me over and over
again. Hey, wherever there's white people there you are also and
I couldn't quite understand what she
was meaning by this but she was really dogging about that. See
she had left the north side of Tulsa for
the specific reason that John Market brought up earlier. The schools
were very good where she
was from
she wanted her son to be educated in the best schools
that she could possibly get her kids into and so
she did and she would do anything possible to
do that. So she went and got a hood home.
And and started renovating that
working night and day, you know with with her with
my father and they worked so hard to do
that and I I
ended up from there kind of
being able to receive some of that blessing. They pushed
me through I got to college and there they
were like man, there's my son he made it. He's in
college. He's about to get his degree and then my
life changed.
I ended up meeting Jesus my senior
year of college and he changed my life
drastically. He's and then
he sent me on a journey that led me to South OKC living
in a low-income apartment complex and
everything that I worked really hard
for to get upward Mobility is now squashed.
I'm now in the southwest side, Oklahoma City.
And God is calling me
to go a different way, but also a
way that leads to life.
and that you know,
that's that's been my story every every
step of the way and it's really beautiful to see this
and to think about this in this way, which is this
I've had a lot of opportunities to be angry.
My what my mom went through
sometimes my dad went through sometimes. Yeah fired from
a job that he did nothing wrong one time and
it was really frustrating for him.
And then they were the boss found out that he got fired and reinstated
him as a whole long thing and it was about racism.
My brother in high school,
he's a freshman and I was
I was a senior and I was you know,
kind of a big guy and had a big friend and I heard some
some noise about somebody calling my my brother and
inward.
And I get upset.
But every step of the way when my mom was doing and when my
grandma was doing was planning seeds that that is not the
way to live.
That is not the way to life.
And so when we heard some some
quotes of James 1:19.
Be slow to anger.
That's a learned skill. That's just
learned skill.
And you know, the the next verse is
really important to James 1:20 says the
anger of man does not produce the
righteousness of God.
my friends
the race conversation needs us to be
people who are humble and who are
slow to anger and also who do not choose the
way of anger and I guarantee because what
the scripture says is true is true that
it will produce the righteousness the opposite effect
of what anger will not do it will produce the righteousness
of God.
And so I am just a big advocate of
that and I've been so so blessed every single step of
the way to even when I do get angry to
have people like Johnson that people like John Mark
Listen to Me Slowly encourage me
and then say Hey, listen, this is
that's not the way and I've had that my whole
life and ultimately I know that it's been Jesus in my
life doing that every step of the way. And so that's been my story but
Well, you are you're encouraging us tonight, and I am very
excited because if you didn't notice, there's only
one young lady on our panel and we finally get to
hear from Tasha and so Tasia and sorry I've
been calling I've been
calling. I've been calling canadra lots of
different names, but I finally got that one down, but taste
it. We're very excited to hear from YouTube.
do just
that get real short and sweet.
I'm messing
around but I want to focus in sharing
my testimony with what reconciliation unaware
looks like when it
goes to stepping into other communities.
I was born and raised on the east side of Oklahoma City
and for fun.
We would go to canadrice side
of town the west side of town and we would get on the bus and
it was called super Saturdays. There was
a church that would come pick us up at the corner, but
they would hit different Corners
in this particular community and they would transport us
to the south side of Oklahoma and all we
did according to me at that time was played
in a lot of candy and
took lots of candy home with us which for
us was a treat and
I didn't realize that that time that
it was seeds being planted.
of racial boundaries not existing because
it was taking time to
get to know people that care for
us that don't look like us when I was
raised in a community of just from the
East side only people that look like us so naturally
having that experience not at a
not as a child really having the Insight of what
this is doing for me, but as I grew up subconsciously
understanding that, you know,
not that there's not race or not
that there's
a lack of like, you know,
people say we don't see some people say we don't see color but
there are differences that are
apparent I I grew up in settings
that
As I travel through life and hearing some
of the experiences that they've had I had experiences but
I didn't have those experiences until I was an
adult because my parents were a
dad to assisted Pastor
my mom. They always kept us in church, but they
born in the 50s. They knew what
was out there that they didn't want us to experience. So we
were in assists sheltered but I
didn't have those experiences directly. My
experience was like I
was the child to say that you're racist that like
no and he's like you'll see when you
get older or you're you're naive. You don't know what
you're talking about. And I and I would we would have those
conversations because it's normalized for
us to talk about experiences and
how it affects us whatever the impact
was. So I wanted to share what it
looks like.
To have those experiences but
have the love of Christ that is taught
in our home. Yes. We have pain that can
put us at risk of having Prejudice. But we
also have the hope of impacted community
that trans that transcends a
lot of those things and inadvertently plant
seeds.
That we that grow as we get older and
not being aware. So that was just like a brief
part of how those little
trips to Super Saturdays and Candy led to
not
emphasizing so much
of our experiences or my
parents experiences to the point where I say. No, I don't want
it. They stay over there. We stay over
here because we're good over here and we'll figure it out, you know,
because reconciliation doesn't look
like that. It's it takes us
back to segregation and separating and
causes us to be offended and that is
just the opposite of what the word
of God teaches us. And so I just wanted to share that.
Thank you, Jason.
We should have more women on this group, but getting
amend in the well, so
I'm gonna and if you could load this first question, the
first question is kind of a softball. What do
we members of Henderson Hills Baptist Church
Disciples of Jesus Christ. What do we need to know?
About having an open and honest dialogue about race and discrimination.
Let me
I'll start us off. So I'm looking
for my I'm a written process. I wrote some things out. So.
The question what do we need to know about having an open honest dialogue about
race and Reconciliation? There's
there's really and I'll try to make
this brief. There's three things. I'm thinking about one of them is that any kind
of dialogue is going to move with the speed of relationship?
It's hard to move the speed of relationship.
And it's not going to move faster than that.
And which means to the second thing which means probably gonna get kind of uncomfortable.
Which I didn't talk about race ethnicity even
saying race.
There's debate about what that even means.
And and some of that is is based
on how much melanin you have in your skin. Would
you think about race?
And so I think being able to even dialogue and get the
same even get the same vocabulary about what we're even talking about.
We'll take relationship.
Think that's the first thing and the second thing is it will take it's movies
to relationship which may not be a fast enough for
so we'll get uncomfortable and and there's
a phrase my mom used to say all the
time was people don't know how much you care how much you know until they
know how much you care. I'm sure you've heard that before.
And I think a lot of us because of our human nature.
We walk into situations thinking that
our perspective is the normal.
perspective
and
and it's not
It may not be it may be in the part of the country that we're in.
It may be in our family, but it may not be the perspective that
that is normal for someone else and I
think the reason relationship is really important is
I've got to be able to love somebody enough.
That when my feelings get hurt and my perspective
gets interrupted. I don't leave the relationship because
I love them.
And so I think those things I think are really
important.
So Chancellor you would say that.
our relationship
correlates with our offendability and if we're easily offended
in a relationships over and so the Futures is
not good. Yeah, I think that's right. And I think there's there's
something else I would say that goes on with that. We just said Phil is that is that
When you enter into this into this space.
A lot of marginalized people don't want
to have open honest conversation with people from the majority of
culture.
Because they've been hurt too much. Yeah.
Or their parents were or their grandparents were or their aunt
and uncle were and they've got stories that validate that and
so until people know that you actually really
do care from both sides. I mean,
I think on the on the other side,
I think a number of white people walk around with
a lot of guilt afraid of an angry
black person coming at them if they express
what they really think.
And the only way to change that is relationship.
to believe someone to trust someone enough
to get down into the room.
Because you get anything to add about that.
All right here.
I think just picking back off of what
you said about, you know things being uncomfortable.
It's going to be uncomfortable and it's not uncomfortable on one
side. Like you mentioned. It's on both sides, but when we're
working through emotions, we have to come and
try to connect we have to come from a place of
curiosity. So it's almost like when we're talking to her
child and our child is telling us something or they're feeling
a lot of emotion and they're really passionate. We
we Overlook the passion or
what they might be presenting to us.
And we ask questions of curiosity. Like where is
this coming from what happened to build
empathy and to you know, bring about
you know relationship. So one of
the things that I think is important is to come from a place of
curiosity and understanding or wanting to understand someone else's
experience so that
they're more comfortable to even open up and say more
Um, and this is really hard to say,
but I think it's important to not
take it personal because sometimes
when we talk about these things, it's it
may feel like oh like you're saying
I did it. I didn't do it like any and you
get into a place where you defending or there's a fence there.
So not taking it personal
but kind of opening your eyes to
Being able to talk to yourself and say I I didn't
do this, but I'd like to know how I can help to change
The Narrative of what is
out there now so and being
and being reflective like how can you contribute
to changing the narrative and
being able to have the conversations just not in within
your community, but how can you step outside of that
community? So that's a little bit of what
I feel like is you know, so the
if you could shape the narrative differently.
And you knew that you weren't going to be offending.
A new white friend if you could never how
would you shape that differently?
Like I know I know that.
We as flawed human beings we'll talk differently in
certain circles than we will in other circles. How can
we how can we do better? How can we talk honestly in
circular? I want to give John Market an opportunity
because he's a he's lived this out.
I'll talk white people to white people.
Here's an observation as as people were sharing stories.
Did you hear how many moms and dads and grandparents came up?
And what we're dealing with is generational trauma
rooted in sin generational sin.
And the Bible has so
much to teach about that.
And what we find is that God's love
is steadfast and he brings healing
generationally, we could talk about a lot of examples. Okay,
let's talk about the Patriarchs in Genesis real quick.
Abraham and Sarah and
Hagar have some issues there's some polygamy
issues some favorite wife favorite cut child issues that
gets passed on to Sibling Rivalry that
becomes fratricidal Strife meaning these people might kill each
other Isaac and Ishmael and it escalates next Generation.
We get Jacob and Esau there's favoritism
and there's rivalry and it escalates the
Next Generation. Jacob's got some favorites and they literally sell
them into slavery because they decided to be merciful instead of
killing him. So the sin is getting passed on and the trauma
is getting passed on generationally, but also each one
is slowly learning each generation is learning how to walk
with God.
And by the time you get to the fourth generation of that family of Patriarchs you
get in Joseph one of the most Godly righteous
humans in the Bible who out of
radical humility and restorative justice
and Grace says what you intended for
evil God intended for good. I'm gonna forgive and because of his Mercy healing
is possible, but it was a generational trauma that
took generations and that means we really need to take seriously.
Generations to heal and that means we need to take seriously First Corinthians 13:4.
Love is patient.
And the question is as white people.
I think one of the things we struggle with is we don't want to deal with our own necessarily
complicity in all of that. I mean,
I started my story one generation back, but I'll tell you.
for most of my early life
Growing up as a poor white kid in an inner
city community in Texas.
I took pride in there may
be a lot of ways in which I'm shamed in this culture, but at least we're not
racist.
And my parents worked hard for everything that they had.
And it wasn't until I was I don't know maybe 30 and
my grandfather was 90 that I heard him. Tell the story of how our people came to,
Oklahoma.
Because they were small-scale farmers in Arkansas who had a few
slaves.
And when they lost those slaves after the Civil War, they couldn't
keep the farm up. They lost the farm and became destitute and came
to Oklahoma for a greater opportunity and that kind of messed up my family narrative.
And so the thing is, okay. Maybe it's not my fault,
but it is my responsibility.
Looking towards the future and as we're dealing
with those generation issues. There's there's predictable things that can happen.
I mean
Here's one of the things as we're talking about our trauma offense. That's
one of the predictable things if we're talking about in the body of Christ the historian
Mark Knoll wrote a great book called God and race in
American history. And one of the things he observes is that if you look at Baptists in
America, you can look at historically black Baptist nominations historically
white Baptist denominations, and we have the same doctrinal statements.
with theologically agree
But we've disagreed about race historically and that has played its
way out politically how we think about what moral issues should
be talked about in the public sphere and what
moral issues we have a responsibility to talk
about and it's affected party alignments.
Such that and one of those denominations if you
self identify as a republican, you won't get kicked out if your
past review that but you might get marginalized and the other denomination if
you self-identify as a Democrat, you won't get kicked out,
but you might get marginalized. I'll let you figure out which one is which on how that goes.
and
Sometimes what starts happening is?
if we start trying to move, okay, Jesus said
or the Bible says we're all one Christ is our peace.
He tore down the wall of hostility and we're quoting all the Bible. So let's come together.
We start worshiping together and praying together and talking about unity and
Reconciliation and then somebody starts talking about
a justice issue. That seems non negotiable to them.
and they quote some Bible verses on it from Isaiah 58 and
Amos 5 and James one and
and they're being biblical.
But to somebody else it sounds like you just
got political.
And here's the thing that is going to happen.
That is going to happen and what often happens then is.
So now I thought I could trust this person as a real Christian, but actually
they're political and they probably thought the same thing.
Until that conversation is just a different different alignment. And
that's the moment where I'm not up here to like sort out how we should
deal with all those policy issues. But that's the moment where we have
to decide is our common relationship with
Jesus enough for us to keep trusting. This
is a brother in the Lord and keep thinking I have something to
learn from them and their experience even if we may not
sort out that political difference this generation.
Mmm, thanks. I think that's some of the patients death.
Thanks for jumping in so I didn't keep talking. No. I told
him I would and every day usually my
wife. I want to go back to something you said.
It's not my fault, but it is my responsibility.
that
if we could how could we live that out Jared you and
I Tulsa and Tulsa had
a really ugly race for at the 20s and it's been
playing out now for way too long. But what does
it look like?
for white communities
to realize that it's not their fault, but
it is their responsibility what I love your story about candy
and super Saturdays and it's
so simple, but it was profound. And so
Jerry, what do you think? What could why
people to do is take responsibility to build relationships.
Yeah.
There's a verse of Philippians. It says let us not
look to our own interests, but also to the interests of
others.
And I really feel like a lot of our
issues deal and stem from a problem
that is really deep.
very historic
goes back to the very beginning. It's Pride.
That's right. It's pride and the the
self-preservation tactics are
innumerable.
They just incredibly normal and
I would.
I would even go as far to say that a lot
of the issues are just the fact that we don't want
to be confronted in our error.
We oftentimes like to live as
if
life is just okay.
As it is, especially when it's going well.
But the problem is is
that the needs of my neighbor are actually my responsibility.
and when I look to the other
side of the town
and somebody else's kid is struggling. Do I
say man?
Those parents they need to get their acts together.
They need to figure it out.
They should be working three and four and five jobs like
my parents did.
Or do we go man?
That kid is struggling. How can I
get in a fight and help?
And I think that's part
of our issue is kind of
a flipping of the script getting out of
self-preservation mode getting out of self-protecting mode and
thinking of people as people to love as
true neighbors and those
they're interests or even greater than my own. That's a
high calling y'all.
Can you imagine that somebody saying that to you could do matching the
Apostle Paul walking up to you and saying Hey, listen that person's
interest over there next to you. It's more
important than your own interest.
Give up yours and seek theirs.
It is it it's an incredible thing,
but if we can get to that place, I think
we could really solve a lot of those issues.
Also, once we get in those conversations, we're
not trying to win an argument.
We're not trying to win a battle.
We don't wage war against flesh and blood.
We we wage war against powers and
principalities guys. This has been generational and
who do we think
was behind all of it?
And the grander scheme of things it was the
powers and principalities the rulers of this air
and this age, but Jesus Christ is
actively working against it.
And to bring victory in the name of Jesus and will
we be on the side of Truth and walk alongside
Jesus as he's reconciling the world
is a real question, but it's gonna look like dying the self.
That's been my answer. Amen. Yeah. Amen.
So Chauncey what did John Mark Hart
do to win your relationship?
That's a really good question. Yeah. Well, let
me tell you that's real
there were
I think there were a number of things.
the first time so
jump workroom is better than I do the first time we met I
remember more the second time we met.
and
it was in a Bible as literature class at the University of Oklahoma.
And I don't remember everything about that class public. I
didn't do much to the homework in a Bible study
class.
It fast enough praise the Lord, but I
do remember the professor saying something.
about
about whether or not the New Testament was all got
inspired something like this and John
Mark called him on it very in a very like masterful educated scholarly
way and the professor recanted
what he said like in class. It was like this dude knows
description third time.
We got time together. We were sitting over Phoenix Oklahoma
campus it was over in Kate Center.
And I think democ might have been trying to recruit me to help in that nonprofit. He
was working with he didn't say that outright, but
I think they might want to happening, but he did give me some advice.
and he said this he said never
settle for a nominal Ministry
never settle for a nominal Ministry
Ministry that's in name only we're saying we're
doing a lot of stuff.
But we're not actually doing what we're saying. We're doing don't ever settle for that.
That was that was number three.
the fourth time we talked
Was when we talked about maybe planting the church together.
and at that time I was I've been
teaching on the south side for
five years four and a half years.
And if you've never taught you don't know what it's like if you
have to you know what it's like and I was pretty burned out.
And I had gone back to a father figure of mine in Norman and he was
I was finding some healing there.
And John Mark asked me to jump on this on this ship.
To go go go do Mission and I was thinking I am
burned out a mission man.
But I thought was praying the Lord said you go and
I'm gonna heal you as you go mmm.
And that first summer the
second summer of the church the church
plant.
We hosted a bunch of guys to come and move
into the south side and live in
our homes and go out and do ministry and before that Summer
started. I'm working out to me and he said hey.
We're gonna be doing a lot of ministry this summer. We got to press out
people at home. Then the apartments we got
to get in the neighborhoods.
He said but I know.
That you work your tail off all year long.
So I really think this summer should be a time of rest
for you.
If you want to come out to the code block parties feel free, but you should
really rest because you're a teacher.
What I'm saying, is that John Mark saw me.
and
without
my initiative he just cared for my soul.
And as like what a 31 year old he shepherded my heart
28 year olds with that. He separated my heart.
And so I think both God told me to follow him. That was
helpful.
But also he earned that.
by just
by just loving me.
and so I think
I think then when it came to other issues I trusted
him.
You know.
I care for him. Yeah, I
gotta
tell you I gotta tell you about the first one. This is really short film the first
one he doesn't remember it. It was a college Ministry party. There
was a dance party Chauncey was the best dancer there
and the coolest guy there and I thought this guy is awesome. And
that's the whole story.
Amity believes that John Mark was the better dancer.
so
this is the last question because I want us to
spend some time together praying.
but
we love to look at Revelation 7 because
it's a picture of the church together every
nation every tribe every tongue and it
says a great multitude that no one can number from every
nation from all tribes and all peoples and all languages will
be standing Before the Throne and before the lamb.
in perfect Unity
But until that great day.
Try to get this down to one or two sentences. I'm gonna let Asia go
first because she she took the shortest while
ago but
She can have a paragraph but until that
great day, how can we Henderson Hills Baptist Church?
promote diversity and inclusion in
our church
I'm prepared for this one, but
I think off the top of my head I remember.
The challenges that I had in the
workplace and I feel
like Henderson Hills can promote diversity
and inclusion by recognizing the
gifts and people a crate
across racial boundaries and putting them
in positions of leadership and serve
it to to open up the access and
communities that you know, you wouldn't normally
serve in so I think that's a start
is, you know to put people in positions to see
what they do well and to Usher them
in and give them opportunities.
Okay.
he had to Revelation 7 is so
beautiful and
When I I think about it.
One thing I think of is this.
the word hospitality
Dr. Clarence Hill, it's a pastor hanging out.
In Norman does
a lot of stuff with the stronger get
together movement has a book called race
to Jesus.
And in it he has a chapter.
On on this topic and on hospitality.
And what I really think is really beautiful about is
this he calls us to Luke 14 faith.
and he calls us to Matthew 13 seed like
Faith you were talking about seeds earlier
and that seat is an important because
What small acts of?
Kindness and faith, can
we do and what greater thing? Can we do
than to open up our home to people intentionally?
I think hospitality is
the way like one
of the ways you think about Revelation 7
and some of the stuff that's around you what we could
maybe just start doing that right now, you know, John 17
talks about eternal life
and we know what eternal life and to see
it's now it's not later. It's it's now because
we know Jesus and the
what's beautiful about when we
open our homes.
When we open our homes to one another I just share with
you really quick. And then I'm a pass it to my friend this week. I
was at something called Community groups that
we we have and I kind
of opened it up after being in Luke
chapter 6 because that's what passes we were in a
week for our sermon.
And my my father-in-law start sharing
about his his journey and how
he had read. Let Justice roll down the two
brought up Joe and and as he
was sharing about let Justice roll down we kind
of went back around a circle and then he kind of
came back to and he said have you guys read that book before?
And many of the people in the group had not
and I had forgotten I had given them
the book in the first place. I was like, yeah, bro I have and he he was
like, he's like, yeah, I know you have you gave me the
book? Okay. Yeah upside. I
forgot about that. But all of
a sudden he starts talking about the fact that in the book John Perkins
had been beaten really badly.
Being so badly that he was left in the pool of
blood.
And he starts breaking down crying.
This breaking down crying and the rest of the group
just kind of stands there and it's like one of those really beautiful
moments as an older white man is
sharing about that and sharing about the Brokenness of pain of someone
else that he didn't know but he read the story and it broke him,
you know.
And here's some other people in the room next
to me and there's another 35 year old
black man, and I wish I had sent you a picture so
you could put it up on the screen, but it's a really beautiful picture of this
man at the
end of our community group and we're just spending time hanging out eating food
and stuff like that together. He just is sitting over
there with us.
like this
listening to my father-in-law
Tell stories and my friends I think that's how
like one of the ways that we're going
to see change. Can we open our
homes up?
Sometimes we we spend a lot of time getting mad at everybody else.
We want them to solve the problems. We want some government
organization to solve the problem when we want the
church to solve the problem. But when
are we going to start taking responsibility and
opening up our homes and opening
up our lives that other people can receive the
blessing of knowing Jesus and I
can receive the blessing of knowing Jesus from
them.
Yeah, yeah.
I think as I've been
Thinking about that question. And you said that earlier Phil and I appreciate that
one thing I thought about is.
Is I think start Where You Are.
Start Where You Are.
If you try to go across the street to minister,
but your own house isn't necessarily in order.
You're not gonna have integrity in the process.
think about act six
the apostles are faced with this issue of
the Greek speaking widows are being neglected and people who brought
that issue to them were.
were the Greek speaking members of the congregation and
so I think there's a reality of just like I
would just encourage you Henderson just to look around.
And see where's the diversity in this church?
Do you know them?
Have you invited them into your home do you eat with them?
Are you doing it here? Because I think I had a buddy of mine
say it doesn't work here don't export it. I think
we've got to have integrity to the process. And so
I think we've got to be listening to each other even in our own congregation.
I'll say three quick things real quick one.
I just want everyone in the room to
hear.
That there's not a heavy burden of condemnation for
our failures, but we're all forgiven and
there's no condemnation in Christ Jesus and really what there is is just an invitation
to Greater Joy and new family.
Because the grace of Jesus so when we're talking about this is not like
we're doing it so bad. We got to figure out how to solve and it fixes
like hey, Jesus loves us right in the mix of our
Brokenness and he's just saying come find the
family that I've been preparing for you. That's the invitation. Second
thing is as we think about
Starting close to home. I think that starts off
and with our own household and with our own local church, but also
sometimes I think in America in particular, we've been
very good at sending internationally, but haven't really dealt with the things
in our own City and our own community. And as as we
deal with that, I would just have two suggestions. One of them is there are
really Godly wise christ-centered
Spirit-filled biblical.
People of color pastors leaders who
are constantly creating spaces
for the people of God to come together and know each other and listen
and learn and showing up for those things would be a great idea.
and I mean, I just mentioned one Clarence Hill that
Jared just mentioned Clarence Hill Jr. Has been a
tremendous.
Christ-centered peacemaking racial reconciliation leader
in Oklahoma for a long time and the stronger together movements got
a couple events coming up a peace walk on April
16th. I think the 60 year
anniversary of Martin Luther King Jr. Letter from Birmingham Jail and that
would be a great time to show up listen in prayer walk
with some saints.
And then in October, there's going to be a neighbor's conference where
there's going to be an opportunity for a diverse group of people to sit at the
feet of a diverse group of people talking about how do we love our neighbors? Well in this
city and that would be a great opportunity to show up and so I'm not I don't know the holy
spirit's calling you to those particular events though. I would love to see you there. But there
are people that are creating those spaces. And
the last thing that I would say is sometimes when we think
about the call to die to ourselves and suffering for Jesus and sharing
and the sufferings of Christ Christians in
America. We kind of do this thing where it's like man overseas they're suffering
but we're so complacent here and we got to go overseas because that's where the real mission
is. But here's the thing if some of those stats that were dropped a
second ago,
about lifespans
correlated to color-coded zip codes in this city.
Or about education attainments in this city, if we
just think about the people about that for a
second and say I want to love my neighbor as
myself which means I care as much
about their kids succeeding academically as I care
about my kids exceeding academically.
I care not only about their spiritual well-being but about
their career opportunities just like for myself or
for my children if we just take that really seriously, we
won't have to have persecutors. We're just going to suffer because
we got a lot of hard work to do.
And a lot it's just inconvenient and it takes
Paradigm shifts and it makes Church less comfortable and more exciting
because the spirit of God will be on the move. So I think that's where
I was done.
We've got two minutes before they let our kids loose so.
Anyway, I just want us to pray together just back here for just a second.
Just through just a spirit of humility answer
this question in your heart.
Am I stuck?
In the way, I view my responsibility.
for racial reconciliation
and in the next question would be
who could I have into my home?
this next year
to show them the love of Jesus.
And lastly ask yourself.
will I pray for my brothers and sisters and
the South Oklahoma City in in East, Oklahoma City
We'll let Joe finish us off.
Father we're so grateful.
Grateful that we've been called to you.
grateful that
you call us your children that we've been adopted into your
family.
And father, it's a family. That's much bigger
than sometimes we think.
and we have
a brothers and sisters
Who are different than us? And
you'll forgive us father for
seeking comfort and seeking
normalcy
And father I pray that you would just
put on our hearts.
a spirit of Adventure
to understand the blessing that's out there for us.
as we learn to reach out to someone that
we may have perceived as other someone that doesn't
look like us.
father there's tremendous blessing in that there's
your Holy Spirit
and dwells
these folks as well.
And so father I pray that.
We would just open our minds to the opportunity for
blessing that's out there.
as we
push past some of our almost self-imposed barriers
that we have
for we know
that your eye is on the sparrow and those
children
those people
that you love
that we can come alongside and minister to
There's blessing in that Ministry.
Father as we live out the opportunity.
to be that Revelation 7 picture
not necessarily all homogenized into
one soup.
But in supporting and loving each other even in our own different cultures.
And that that happens because we had
have relationships.
And so I just pray that we just reach out to that
someone.
Or make some inquiries.
Do some reading.
By that we would know your heart.
Even better. So we thank you for this time
today. We thank you.
For Jared and Chauncey John Mark, Asian, Phil.
for setting this up and
for sharing their hearts
father
they are serving you they're living you through this.
And thank thank you.
for their blessing
to us tonight.
We give you praise and we give you thanks and the precious name
of Jesus Amen.
Let's give our panel one. Great. Thank you.